all right let's start today with news
out of Russia and Ukraine these
headlines are sort of unbelievable I
I've been a stop short of calling them
kafka-esque but it's almost appropriate
the Associated Press reports that
Vladimir Putin the Russian president has
declared martial law
in the annexed regions of Ukraine now
that headline might make sense if that
there was really an annexation that took
place what we're really talking about is
occupied regions of Ukraine
in which Putin is claiming sovereignty
but in which there really is no
sovereignty and so it's kind of a weird
thing to say I'm declaring martial law
in parts of a different country which is
fundamentally what Putin is doing but of
course his perspective would be a
different one let's look at a little bit
of this article and we'll talk about the
reasons for this and the implications
and sort of what comes next
um Associated Press once again Russian
President Vladimir Putin declared
martial law Wednesday in the four
regions of Ukraine that Moscow annexed
and gave additional emergency powers to
the heads of all regions of Russia Putin
didn't immediately spell out the steps
that would be taken under martial law I
think we can guess some of them but said
his order was effective starting
Thursday his decree gives law
enforcement agencies three days to
submit specific proposals and orders the
creation of territorial Defense Forces
in those four annexed regions the um
this statement here from Putin again
it's it's all extremely dystopian quote
we are working to solve very difficult
large-scale tasks to ensure Russia's
security and safe future to protect our
people
huh those who were on the front lines
are undergoing training at firing ranges
and training centers should feel our
support and know that they have our big
great country and unified people behind
their back sounds a little bit trumpy
quite frankly
um the Associated Press article also
adds the Upper House of Russia's
Parliament was set to quickly seal
Putin's decision to impose martial law
again the regions we're talking about
are danets Carson luhansk and zapparizia
draft legislation indicates it may
involve restrictions on travel and
public Gatherings tighter censorship and
broader Authority for law enforcement
agencies think about the Evil Genius of
this right
uh it's not even your country you say oh
yeah we're annexing these parts of the
country
it's not formally done and I got it I I
understand that when a country is
annexing part of another the idea of
formality often what you're talking
about is just years of it sort of being
under the control and then you say well
I guess now it's kind of annex that
definitely has not happened and then you
say now that this is part of our country
and we've annexed this we're going to
impose further restrictions and further
repress and suppress reporting from the
area Etc the belief there's a few
different beliefs sort of like most
likely lowest hanging fruit priorities
here
one would be
legal cover for the wave of repressions
that are certainly that is certainly to
come as absurd as that cover is hey this
is Russia now and so now we're imposing
martial law the other aspect of this and
a couple people wrote to me said you
know David it's kind of silly to say
you're like imposing martial law in any
kind of formal way because
it's a war zone and so by definition
it's all kind of under the control at
least ostensibly of the military so to
now declare the martial law it's it kind
of is under a de facto martial law type
situation because it's militaries
fighting each other
um we're looking at a forced
mobilization of ukrainians in the area
to start getting the ukrainians out and
this is by many reasonable assessments a
war crime but by pretending that this is
now Russia that these four regions are
part of Russia and that the individuals
there are Russian because remember he's
quote annexed it
it's I don't I don't want to call it
plausible but it sort of is a one
percent attempt at claiming that what
you're doing is just the the governance
of your own country rather than an
alleged War crime so it's Bonkers and
it's crazy and of course we continue to
wonder about what is the end game here
there does not seem to be a face-saving
off-ramp for Vladimir Putin here and
increasingly the questions among the
United States and Western allies
continue to be
how far do we allow this to go and for
how long and what are the sort of red
lines at which point different
interventions would happen
for how long and to what degree and in
what particular ways do we again U.S
Western allies NATO Etc sort of these
vend Circles of those individual groups
continue to fund and Supply Ukraine and
um
at what point do we imagine that the
circumstances may change and there
aren't really good answers to that in
the U.S as is often the case the
conversation becomes what I call
toxically partisan and what I mean by
that is of course if different
individuals with different world views
would have different opinions about what
should be done in Russia obviously more
isolationist individuals would say we
should do nothing
we shouldn't even send money sent note
don't send arms send nothing at all
don't send legs don't send anything
um that's a joke by the way others would
say well we we send money but not arms
or we send money and arms but absolutely
nothing beyond that or well what about
training and then of course at the very
far end of that would be sort of boots
on the ground the unfortunate thing is
that when I say it's become toxically
partisan you have many right Wingers who
seek only to attack Joe Biden who take
the position that Biden is just wasting
money in Ukraine now a lot of these same
people earlier were saying Biden hasn't
done enough to protect the Ukrainian
people and Russia never would have even
invaded if Trump was President so you
you can't really get anywhere with about
60 to 70 percent of people on this issue
I I'm really willing to entertain
reasonable perspectives I don't want to
say from both sides but regardless of
political ideology I'm willing to
entertain reasonable perspectives that
will both uh not allow Russia to just
walk all over whoever they want to walk
over while also not committing or
involving the United States in a way
that would be
either counter counterproductive or not
particularly appropriate given that we
should not be the world's police any I'm
willing to entertain any reasonable
ideas that fall under that umbrella if
you have any as to what this should look
like feel free to email me